gluten intolerance self-report gluten
intolerance has increased from 3 to 30
in 10 years human biology hasn't changed
that much is it maybe that the foods
have changed and people are responding
to that or is it maybe some sort of
expectation because the type of news
stories that are hearing about gluten
and about how bad it is for us and
inflammation and all this sort of stuff
maybe it's that and people are expecting
it so they brought people into a lab VO2
max tests that they were looking at
apparently there's a particular genetic
mutation that allows people to blow off
CO2 and up regulate oxygen in a better
way they brought people in of people
that didn't did not have this genetic
trait split them into two random groups
so it was a mix of both do and do not
have the trait in each but when they
actually looked at what was happening in
the physiology of these people they
found that the people who didn't have
the genetic mutation but were told that
they did had a lower overall lactate
threshold they had a lower overall heart
rate they were blowing off CO2 more
effectively and upregulating oxygen
better than the people who did have the
genetic mutation but were told that they
didn't so he coined this term that said
your expectations are even more powerful
than your genes